all right now it's time for WTF what the
faila joining me now is Jimmy phela host
of fox Across America Jimmy it's been so
long
I'm going to try not to get emotional
I've missed you but in the past you and
I have talked about a Tick-Tock Trend
called bare minimum Mondays but now gen
Z women I understand are taking this to
like a whole new level this new trend is
called Lazy Girl jobs and the New York
Post says the trend emerged as an
antidote to girl boss hustle culture
choosing balance over career progression
here's one of the lazy girls Jimmy
I sat there and I tried to be the best
performing person and I worked extra
nights and blah blah blah and I didn't
get any more of a raise than I did just
doing the second worst best effort
that's who gets amazed it's not the
person that's like quietly like grinding
the whole time so just be the second
worst on your team and just go live your
life
Jimmy what about the Lazy Boy jobs
first of all I don't think you can call
them a girl boss I think it's a them
boss at this point but what a weird
thing man like I grew up with a
generation of women who wanted to break
the glass ceiling now they just want to
take a selfie next to it and call it a
day but the one thing I learned out of
this trend Laura is this does explain
why Kamala won't go near the border she
you know you're not going to get a raise
if you solve the problem under this
world view so you might as well mail it
in have some good work-life balance
right
if she's the second laziest who's the
first laziest Administration though
that's the problem all right Jimmy I
have to move on to this other Trend
which is Jeep owners are reportedly
putting rubber ducks on each other's
cars for fun and it's called ducking now
some have taken I guess social media to
show us what it all looks like watch
this all right I got ducked yet again
oh my God it's an aerial duck
let's see what the note says
look at this duck isn't it neat
Jimmy you're a Bronco owner I understand
is there any ritual that you want to
tell us about because this is really
pathetic
no this is like weird this rubber duck
craze like who started this Burton Ernie
like it makes no sense but here's the
thing Laura if you go on to the Facebook
page they founded for this you start to
get it the reason these rubber ducks are
so popular is if you look at most of
these people this is the only rubber
they're ever going to get a chance to
use
oh
I knew somehow I knew it was going to
do that it was gonna
get there I knew it I knew it I knew it
I knew it we got to get them in while we
can I'm gonna get Tommy for that one and
Jimmy we also have some um more AI
warning signs apparently ai-powered
humanoid Bots boasting that they were
better equipped to run the world than
humans at a un Summit on Friday now
here's some actual footage from Geneva
this was last week of that exact robot
watch
I believe the humanoid robots have the
potential to lead with a greater level
of efficiency and Effectiveness in human
leaders
we don't have the same biases or
emotions that can sometimes Cloud
decision making and can process large
amounts of data quickly in order to make
the best decisions
Jimmy aside from the fact that the
robots obviously gender fluid
um would you vote for an AI robot for
president of the world
I I feel bad breaking the news to them
but they already tried running a robot
for president but no one voted for
Hillary
so I don't know if the reboot is going
to come any better the only thing I took
out of this is this is the proof that
the robots are going to kill us they're
admitting they want to be in charge
we're obviously not going to let them so
at some point they're going to have to
procure power through other means I'm
telling you Ingram I'm starting I'm
starting a militia next time you see me
on here no more of these overweight
figure skater shirts I'm going to be
wearing camo I don't think we're going
to have Lazy Girl robots I think robots
are actually just going to do the job
right they're not going to be talking
about work-life balance so that might be
at least they'll show up for work you
know what yeah voting robot it can't do
any worse than the humans we have run in
the country now we finally have some
movement on the cocaine gate story axios
reporting that the Secret Service is
planning now to update Congressional
staff on Thursday after denying that
foia request that we talked about
earlier so what's going on
isn't it so funny to think that Biden
was supposed to restore decency to the
Oval Office now they're filming a sequel
to Whose Line Is It Anyway
like this is crazy they know who has it
whoever did it they know obviously they
could have solved this within a few
hours they're not happy with the answer
so we're getting you know this sort of
thing but if you believe they're on the
level you're doing more cocaine than
whoever left it there this could be a
scene from Scarface on some desk in the
in the White House at this point Jimmy
great to see you thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else